now here's a look at what's coming up on
c-span just ahead new york stock
exchange chairman and CEO richard Grasso
on the relationship between the world's
financial markets then the latest stop
on our Tocqueville tour from Columbia
South Carolina after that Wednesday
State Department briefing on the
situation with Iraq and later Housing
and Urban Development secretary Andrew
Cuomo on homelessness in America's
cities now from the Economic Club of
Washington DC New York Stock Exchange
chairman and CEO Richard Grasso last
night he spoke about the relationship of
the US economy and the world's financial
markets the program's 45 minutes if I
could have your attention
Thank You friends our bylaws require
that we take care of a little club
business before we begin the evenings
program let me introduce the chairman of
the nominating committee Peter O'Malley
mr. chairman thank you very much our
nominating committee has done its usual
splendid job we've fed we have available
in the back of the room the Virginia
Board of Election Supervisors they are
prepared to accredit the group that
we're going to nominate if you see fit
to elect them as you know the club's
board of directors consists of 26
members eight of these have completed
their second three-year term in
accordance with our bylaws they are
stepping down from the board the
departing board members are Terry Newmar
David Lambert Steve Harlan Dan Callahan
Jerry Hawk Doug mccorkadale Harry
McPherson and the vacancy created
earlier when bill Hodges moved to
Charlotte last year would you join me in
a round of applause recognizing their
hard work
the good news is that replacing Harry
McPherson and Terry Newmar on the board
of directors does not affect their terms
as officers of the club so there is less
urgency to have the Board of Elections
convene in the back of the room we have
a very capable slate the nominating
committee recommends that the following
persons be elected as new members of the
board
Anthony mizelli gene Conley John Derek
Galan Hampton raela plaka Barbara Nikki
and Susan Williams mr. president I move
approval of the slain of directors put
forward by the nominating committee is
there a second all those in favor let it
be known by saying aye all those opposed
thank you there Slade is elected
ladies and gentlemen we have a two
special guests from the diplomatic
community with us tonight the ambassador
of Belgium is excellently aundrea dom
and the ambassador of Italy is
excellency ferdinando's Alejo would you
give them let me review our format after
mr. Grasso presentation I'll moderate
the question-and-answer period their
cards at your tables
please write legibly and get them up
here to me and I'll put them to mr.
Grasso dick Grasso is beginning his 30th
year with the New York Stock Exchange he
joined it in 1968 and he has had a broad
range of assignments ever since then he
was elected chairman and chief executive
officer in 1995 for the previous seven
years he had been president and chief
operating officer
he is the first staff member I wanted
here's a little applause from anybody
who's ever been a staff man he's the
first staff member in the 205 years of
the New York Stock Exchange to be
elected to any of the exchanges top
leadership positions and he is the
chairman
he is committed to maintaining the
exchanges preeminence in the global
equities market he was talking to me at
dinner about the size of this market and
maybe you'll have a chance to give you
that number as he speaks this evening
about the justice that the amount that
the dollar amounts that are involved in
the new york stock exchange it's a
staggering to anybody even somebody
who's worked in the government for a
while he is he is a member of the board
of directors of Computer Associates
international he's a member of the
International Capital Markets advisory
committee for the Fed and he serves on
the board of directors of the National
Italian American Foundation the police
foundation the board of and the Advisory
Board of the Yale School of organization
and management
he's also an extremely nice guy as I
have learned it's a give me great
pleasure to welcome to the economic of
Washington the chairman of the New York
Stock Exchange
Richard Grasso
thank you very much Harry good evening
ladies and gentlemen those very warm
remarks are deeply appreciated on behalf
of all staff members everywhere I'm
deeply honored to be with you this
evening I want to thank the Board of the
Economic Club I particularly want to
thank my partner David Lambert outgoing
board member there are so many members
of the New York Stock Exchange extended
family here tonight that I know I'll get
myself in deep trouble if I start naming
names but suffice to say so many of our
listed companies are member broker
dealers and those that have been
enormous ly important to the success of
our great institution are here tonight
and I thank you for taking time out I
will however depart and offer one very
special acknowledgement it was about 22
years ago that I started working on a
particular account having been at the
exchange since 1968 I was finally given
an assignment it was to try and do
something important list a new company
and of course being a rookie of some
three or four years I did all that I
could to foil the business from joining
us but it was at Kalani who was here
tonight who rescued me and Ed I want to
thank you for being such a great friend
to a young intern because that was a
very important part of my early career
at the exchange the listing of Allegheny
and I truly thank you for being a friend
20 for better than 20 years and your
sponsorship and guidance at that time
was very important to me I'm delighted
I'm delighted to be here because this is
a time of extraordinary challenge for
those of us in markets and particularly
in a town like this one where if there
is a constancy it has changed I am
deeply honored to be invited to this
club and most humbled to have been
introduced by Harry because of course
the you know him better than I at the
club but for the better part of four
decades he's been advisor to presidents
and to opinion leaders and it is for me
a very special honor that you would
introduce me tonight Harry and I thank
you for that it is a time of
unprecedented opportunity and yet great
challenge and great questioning in
markets today the New York Stock
Exchange finished last year as the most
active in its history some 133 billion
shares having changed hands on the big
board that would be 100 times the first
full year of my experience of the Nysa
and as Harry mentioned in the
introduction I did indeed join the New
York Stock Exchange in the 20th century
in a period in a period of some 30 years
we've gone from a marketplace with a
valuation of less than a trillion
dollars to one that today approaches 12
trillion dollars but more importantly
than the scale and size of the New York
Stock Exchange is the breadth and
participation that we enjoy in this
country of the American populations
involvement in the marketplace truly
today some 60 million Americans are
direct participants in our markets and
when one looks to the indirect
participation almost 200 million
Americans are impacted by what happens
on the floor of the New York Stock
Exchange each day that is a very special
honor and privilege it takes
a command responsibility of serving the
largest and the smallest with the same
level the same level of care and
oversight it is a marketplace that in
May of this year will celebrate its two
hundred and sixth anniversary and yet it
is a marketplace that ten years ago did
not have the privilege of trading 2,000
of the 3,000 companies that we are today
privileged to trade so we are almost as
old as this great nation itself and yet
as young as the newest IPO to join our
ranks we are a marketplace that
increasingly is seeing the effect of
globalization and that is the subject
I'd like to touch upon this evening
globalization and the interconnects that
exist between markets and economies all
over the world 1997 was a benchmark year
for the securities industry and for
investors in this country the third year
of 20 plus rates of return on the Dow
Jones Industrial Average and greater
rates of return on some of the broader
averages it was for the New York Stock
Exchange a year in which we listed a
record number of non-us companies that
non-us record as proud as we are of it
is simply a forerunner of what we expect
the years ahead to produce and yet given
what has happened and particularly in
the fourth quarter of last year what
happened in the markets in Asia there
are many that are asking the question
are we going in the wrong direction is
globalization the wrong strategy is this
interconnected nature of markets and
economies going to produce some evil as
you might expect from me the short
answer is emphatically no I believe that
the benefits of globalization the
benefits of interconnect
far outweigh the challenges and the
downsides that indeed we've experienced
late last year it is important I think
to put the challenge of globalization
into context globalization is a social
and political interconnect it is beyond
economics and finance and we believe
certainly economies and those
representing countries from all over the
world who visit share this view that it
is largely and thankfully the result of
globalization and interconnected markets
that we today worry about not the loss
of lives but the loss of dollars clearly
there are enormous risks inherent in
maturing emerging and pre emerging
markets but is that not a much better
position to being concern about
volatility and currencies and the
movement of troops is that not a unique
opportunity is we as we look at America
today with virtually no alternative
economic model anywhere a unique moment
in our history the disciplines of the
free market process equity ownership
being the tool that will fuel the growth
of companies and countries that will
bring peace as distinguished from
centrally managed debt driven economies
of alternative economic directions that
not too many years ago brought peril to
world order this is a unique time and a
time yet having experienced the delight
of the latter part of October and I must
say in all candor that October of 1997
was very different than October of
nineteen
87 and yet equally dark on the 27th when
investors saw the Dow Jones Industrial
Average folsome 354 points on what was
to that point the most active day in our
history and yet
a day later 1.2 billion shares change
hands on the New York Stock Exchange and
the market rallies some 350 plus points
it defined for us a moment to reflect
and to look upon the opportunities that
globalization are presenting clearly
there are questions to be raised for
those markets and particularly those
economies that have let their growth and
their flow of funds outstrip their
ability to oversee and discipline both
the public and private sectors but
that's not a reason to abandon this
process that started just two decades
ago with the beginnings of privatization
coming from the Thatcher government
rolling around the world Europe Latin
America Asia we find ourselves today at
a unique moment clearly a moment when we
must pause to reflect the reflection I
think that we need to take in terms of
what has happened in the Pacific Rim and
gain some insight by looking at the
experiences we had just a few short
years ago with our neighbor to the south
and how fortunate we were to have had at
the moment of crisis in the Mexican
economy to have had the leadership at
the Treasury from Bob Rubin with the
support of the Congress to bring about
structural reform and to return that
economy to a path of sustainable growth
with low inflation with the proper
incentives built to channel capital at
rates that were realistic and indeed
we gained some insight as to how we must
act when other parts of the world
trading partners to this great nation
are challenged by some of the same very
significant structural damages
globalization though should not be
looked upon as having passed it's
accelerating the globalization trend
with one were to look simply at a period
of ten years nineteen eighty eight forty
programs worldwide raise about forty two
billion dollars ten years later double
the number of programs and almost 100
billion dollars and that is still an
embryonic level when one considers the
prospects that are out there at the New
York Stock Exchange using a very narrow
lens if I were to size for this audience
the opportunity in the global theater
and compare it to our domestic
opportunity I suspect there would be
great surprise in America today or at
least at the end of last month there
were fewer than 750 domestic
corporations publicly traded qualified
to be on the New York Stock Exchange
that were traded elsewhere if we were to
fully tap that market opportunity bring
every one of those companies to our
market tomorrow trust me ladies and
gentlemen we would be delighted to
experience that sudden rush of demand
upon our capabilities if we were to do
that we would add one trillion dollars
of value to the New York Stock Exchange
outside of the United States the picture
is quite different again at the end of
last month we measure an estimate that
approximately 2,700 non-us companies
meet the quantitative tests for listing
on the New York Stock Exchange the top
one-third of that audience of
opportunity were to join the New York
Stock Exchange ranks would add
most seven trillion dollars to our
marketplace and those numbers are before
the privatization effect the
privatization effect of course is an
estimate at best and most times the
estimate is quite far from reality but
again through the way a very narrow lens
if you were to look at the experience
with Deutsche Telekom November of 1996
when Dorsett telecom listed on the New
York Stock Exchange its value was the
equivalent of 6% of the then domestic
opportunity for the New York Stock
Exchange's ranks I use those numbers to
underscore the enormity of opportunities
that exist not just for the New York
Stock Exchange but for American
investors American investors continue
notwithstanding this level of challenge
that we experienced in the second half
of 1997 American investors continue to
be aggressive in the pursuit of
diversification to the worldwide theater
of economies that are emerging existing
and some in the pre emerging state if
you were to look as we've measured
amongst our broker dealer organizations
at the trendline you found that last
year the level of individual investor
participation in non-us securities grew
to about 10% of the portfolio's
composition that number most experts
agree will double in the next seven
years it will double at a time when
issuers from around the globe
increasingly will seek capital outside
of their domestic markets and thus the
excitement at the Nysa we finished 1997
with a record number of non-us companies
record number joined us last year and we
ended at 343 which would have been
almost four times the level of seven
years ago and yet my partners and I
believe that
three years from now the number will be
double the level of trading activity on
the nyo see each day last year some 526
million shares changed hands roughly ten
percent of that activity was based or
contributed from non-us securities that
too is a number that is
disproportionately small and again the
lens the narrow lens of the NYC offers
some insight as to the prospects that
lie ahead if one were to look at 1994
and 1995 as a bench the most actively
traded security on our marketplace for
both of those years was not an American
company it was the telephone company of
Mexico amongst the five most actively
traded last year from a dollar volume
standpoint
tellah bras the Brazilian telephone
company and I think it is a very
important indicator to those in markets
to those in public policy and certainly
to those in the investor community of
the dynamism that was started some 20
years ago we are in a period right now
of unprecedented returns given the last
three years
enormous questions being raised as to
the desirability of the interconnected
nature of markets and yet at a time when
ladies and gentlemen I offer at least a
personal view that this is not a process
that you want to reverse this is a
process that we must stabilize and
accelerate if you were to look at the
wonderful leadership I think that this
administration has brought to the
problems they have offered very very
significant reforms requisite to the
programs of assistance and I believe
that is going to offer to those
countries most in need of our help the
right solution if you were to look at
the initiatives from the private sector
we at the New York Stock Exchange have
offered all markets emerging pre
emerging and those that are
repositioning the opportunity to come to
the NYC and learn our process clone our
technology if they choose but most
importantly embrace our system of
regulatory oversight because the system
here in this country I believe has
contributed to the success and depth and
breadth of participation that we today
enjoy the partnership between the
markets the regulator's that oversee
markets and of course the Congress has
built a model that is truly the envy of
the rest of the world looking at the NY
I see through the lens of what happened
last October I think is a very important
forecaster of what we might expect in
the years ahead the week ending the 31st
of October was an important one from a
number of different perspectives for us
it was the first time in our history
that four billion shares changed hands
in a single week the first time that 1
billion shares traded in a single day
and of course the first time in the
history of markets
I believe anywhere that the president of
China would ring the opening bell it was
though more than symbolic it was a visit
of great importance not just to those in
markets but I believe to all Americans a
signal that there is going to be reform
in the PRC there is going to be an
embracement of the principles and
disciplines of the free market process
and we have offered our collective
expertise of the securities industry
that I so proudly represent to try and
help that government get to the
structural reforms that can lead to the
proper economic incentives that will
ultimately I believe the important to
the contributing successes that will be
sought in the air
of social reform as we looked through
the lens of October of 1997 we at the
New York Stock Exchange have some work
to do the most active week in our
history the most active day in our
history a test and a real live test for
our capacity and the sturdiness of our
process I'm proud to say that we did
indeed make the proper investments over
the last seven years in technology which
enabled us to handle that 1.2 billion
years on the 28th without flaw indeed at
no time that day were we above 40 and 47
percent utilization of our technology
base something that I think was
important but it equally was important
for us those the operators of the market
to recognize that we have work to do
because if we can trade 1.2 billion
shares in a single session it is not
going to be very long before 1.2 billion
shares will be an average day and if 1.2
billion shares becomes an average day
then clearly we will see peak days well
in excess of 3 billion shares and indeed
we are planning for that today we have
the capacity to handle almost 3 billion
shares this time next year I'm hopeful
that we'll be up somewhere between four
and five two and a half to three years
from now comfortably in excess of six
billion shares and I believe that will
be the challenge that our marketplace
will face it will be faced with that
challenge based on broaden participation
here in the US more and more investors
coming into the market as Americans to
take charge of their finances understand
that they've got to save and invest and
indeed as international issuers
recognize that a pool of capital the
largest and deepest in the world awaits
those company
that are prepared to meet the rigors of
a registration in the United States and
the disciplines of transparency and
governance that US investors have come
to appreciate and indeed have come to
expect we are in a period where emerging
markets are maturing I would hope that
the experience of last October tells us
one thing in any sharp growth cycle
there will be Corrections it is
important again to look at history 32
years ago the Dow Jones Industrial
Average crossed 1,000 for the first time
since its creation back in 1896 what few
people remember is coincident with the
Dow at a thousand so too was the Nikkei
225 in the period 1966 through 19 6 1989
we watched the Dow go from a thousand to
2,700 back to 1600 and then marginally
above 2,000 in that same time frame we
watched the Nikkei go from 1000 to
38,000 back to 12,000 and now to its
current level of some 15,000 again I
think a very important reminder that
markets do not simply go in one
direction but that long-term investment
certainly if you were to take a time
horizon of greater than seven years the
typical investor in that seven year time
horizon has been handsomely rewarded
with a premium being in the equities
market over the fixed-income alternative
way today at the NYC find ourselves in a
period of growth beyond even those who
are closest to the institution's wildest
expectations again history is an
important for teller of what's in front
it took the New York Stock Exchange from
its founding in 1792 until 1977 a period
of 185 years to list 25 billion shares
in the last 25 years that in the last
excuse me 20 years since the spring of
1977 we've watched that 25 billion
shares grow to more than 200 billion
shares we are a marketplace that has
never been larger either as to its
capitalization the number of investors
who participate each day in the price
discovery process and the number of
great companies that we're privileged to
trade and yet there's a common
denominator the traces to our founding
and that is each day in each transaction
what we do we do through the lens of the
least sophisticated user of the market
if we can protect that user if we can
say to that small consumer you the
investor for 100 shares have been
treated as fairly and have had the same
opportunity to capture a transaction be
it a sale or a purchase as the largest
institutional user of our market we will
have served our mission but more
importantly we will have reinforced the
public's confidence in the marketplace
here in the United States we are so
fortunate in the u.s. to have built a
model a listed model and a dealer model
that serve our base of great companies
so well we are in a time frame when
those who question the market both from
a an interconnected globalization
standpoint and from a performance
standpoint can easily find company and
yet I would say it is important to
recognize that those with long vision
have been truly rewarded by their
patients and
due diligence it is not unlike the
questions I'm sure that we're asked
about the u.s. some 150 years ago when
it would have been easy to look at what
was happening here in the United States
and question the viability of this model
it is important and I believe imperative
upon all in both the public and private
sectors to support and to support with
conviction the initiatives that are
coming from the administration admission
an administration set of initiatives
designed to bring about structural
reform and some of the emerging company
companies and countries that are
suffering and yet it is equally
important that we not abandon this model
if you were to look at the great
American companies the five largest that
I'm privileged to trade on my exchange
you would find that on average they earn
more than half of their revenues outside
of the United States consumer market
opportunities are broadening the
opportunity for cross-border
transactions never larger last year a
half a trillion dollars on the NYC in
non-us securities more than 2.2 trillion
of trade in the cross-border global
sense it is a time of unprecedented size
for markets huge challenges for those
who oversee markets and yet a time when
I believe we in the business community
must support this I believe very
positive affirmative role that we played
at the administration in terms of
bringing about the proper levels of
change that must take place markets have
a history a well-defined long history of
overreacting but it is also well known
that in overreaction comes opportunity
an opportunity is observed by smart
investors
I believe those many in this audience
who can see the course and who can look
above this current Valley will be
handsomely rewarded because markets in
my view will grow in their interconnect
in their mutual dependency and that will
be good not just for the business the
business of business but for the world
thank you very much for having me here
I was about to ask if all smart
investors would please stand up here
we'll get on with our questions dick
people on the East Coast who get up at a
reasonably early hour have been waking
up to reports of what happened overnight
in Hong Kong and Tokyo within the stock
markets and what happened during the
morning in the European markets do you
worry about the contagion effect that
reports from far-flung markets can have
on the American market well the the
answer is clearly yes as evidenced by
the fact that in my role today it's
probably wise not to go to sleep but in
reality while there is clearly a wave
that can communicate best evidence of
that 27 October of last year it started
in Asia moved to Europe and then of
course we had our 554 point down day
there clearly is an interconnected
factor I think markets have become smart
enough to recognize and to to
differentiate economies companies within
respective economies and so while there
can be a crowding while there can be a
hurting effect I suspect the the answer
lies better in the twenty-eighth than in
the 27th because investor rationale
returns to markets that right themselves
and there are those who believe that a
difference of a day can be an
extraordinary difference those who
question that look at if you will the
sentimental change between the close of
business on the 27th and mid morning on
the 28th there is clearly an
interconnect effect it clearly will
impact but I believe markets in
particular
the investor today in this market are
smarter than ever before and do the due
diligence of differentiation this is a
question I think the whole bunch of
people here will have a interest in and
maybe a lot of opinions about how do you
feel about the use of circuit breakers
in the market and do you foresee any
changes in that in the near term well as
I as I've said publicly right at the
time of the October event the circuit
breakers that are in place today need to
be reformed but I do believe in the
final analysis that some form of timeout
some level of market downside experience
should cause us to take a breather the
current the current breakers are a too
low and be too narrowly defined at our
upcoming board meeting we will discuss a
series of initiatives designed to change
the The Breakers but I do believe it is
important particularly for the retail
consumer to have a timeout to have the
ability to step back and say this market
has had a dramatic downturn does it make
any sense should I not do what I'm about
to do and I believe there is a there is
a general feeling amongst individual
investors that that is a wise course to
pursue but clearly the point levels that
we currently have in place are non
reflective of the size of the market
recognized as I know most in this
audience do that they were established
on a very different base years ago
number one the new breakers will be
percentage based they will be
considerably higher than the current
levels and there will be bandwidth
between the first level and any multiple
level thereafter
what impact will the discount internet
brokerage businesses have on more
traditional larger brokerage house
well the deployment of the internet or
the so-called electronic trading
alternative broker-dealers is having an
impact on virtually every part of the
the brokerage community so much so that
many are now splitting their own brands
into a discount brand and a and an
internet brand I believe what's what's
very clear is that there is a consumer
base out there that does not want the
traditional services offered by
intermediation however that is a
relatively small universe today it's in
I believe incumbent upon those
intermediaries to recognize the
differences in customer attitudes and
many are already recognizing that by the
introduction of what they'll term their
broker dealer light alternatives home
access to the network of a particular
firm internet interconnect capabilities
and by the way some have gone to the
extent of driving that right down to the
marketplace level today if one were to
call a broker dealer member of the New
York Stock Exchange and offer an order
to buy or sell less than 2,000 shares of
any listed security that transaction
from your brokers desk will be emailed
to the floor of the exchange introduced
to the price discovery process executed
and back on your brokers terminal in 22
seconds on an average day in 1998
roughly 81 percent of my trades
producing 40% of my volume are handled
in the manner I've just described so
technology becomes an enabler
it doesn't necessarily displace what it
creates is a
tool for those who deploy it effectively
dick as markets become more global and
active what are the prospects and plans
for the New York market to remain open
for 24 hours well that'll air that'll
certainly solve our problem of having to
wake up to a market report from
elsewhere I think it's it's very
important to recognize that we are still
a relatively embryonic international
market ten percent of our companies or
non-us companies approximately 10
percent of our daily activity being
generated by those those companies
heavily concentrated in the
latin-american security base but there
is clearly going to come a time when the
mix of trading on the New York Stock
Exchange and the types of companies
traded will be more heavily weighted to
the world's market rather than to the
domestic market and I say that in the
sense that as we look of the last ten
years capital markets or the equity
portion of capital markets have grown
from nine trillion to 22 trillion
worldwide I believe that the hours a
marketplace will operate from will be a
function of the mix of investors the mix
of issuers and the contribution of
trading volume it is clear to me 24
hours may stretch it a bit hairy but
there will come a time in the next five
to seven years when I wouldn't be
surprised that the New York would be a
sixteen to twenty hour a day market that
we would be trading in currencies other
than the US dollar and that non-us
securities would trade as they do today
in the American deposit format and in
the ordinary format that would give us a
market model which would allow
institutions from around the world as
well as the least sophisticated retail
consumer from right here in the US to
participate on an equal footing
I don't however look forward to a
24-hour market and I'll tell you very
simply because there is a need to pause
for valuation clearance comparison and
settlement and most importantly for a
little bit of sleep mm-hmm
how are you fixed how is the exchange
fixed for the year 2000 of your computer
systems well fortunately since we we
only commenced building the
infrastructure some 22 years ago most of
it is it is either converted to y2k
compliant or never had the same types of
problems that some of the older
infrastructures in the in the broader
community have it's not sufficient
though for me to say the New York Stock
Exchange is prepared and ready for the
stroke of midnight 1999 passing into the
next millennium
I've got 560 broker-dealer members who
must also be able to service and
interconnect with me they've got 10,000
institutional customers I'm building of
course the scenario that most are
familiar with this is an interconnected
problem of financial services to the
broader and virtually the entire
spectrum of Commerce here in the US and
we can't stop it right there
the year 2000 indeed will happen in
parts other than the United States and
so it is a worldwide issue that I must
tell you in all candor no matter how
well-prepared we as a single participant
may be it is those who interface with us
that we've got to be be certain are
compliant our broker dealers are going
to be working with us this year to make
certain that they are indeed compliant
and we are working with other agencies
to make certain banks insurance
companies at least the financial sector
as we defined the overseen marketplace
is prepared but I will tell you in
candor again 'harry on the stroke of
midnight December 31st 1999 I will not
be in an elevator well ladies and
gentlemen I think we we've all had a
good demonstration apply dick Grasso
rose from being a runner in the New York
Stock Exchange to being its chairman and
we want to thank you very much dick for
an extremely enlightening talk by a very
serious person who is managing the
well-being of an awful lot of Americans
and people around the world and as a
tribute to you and for you to take back
would like you to have this American
Eagle from the Steuben collection as our
as a tribute to you and our thanks to
you for an excellent talk and thanks so
much Richard Roth
that Harry I thank you the board and
everyone in attendance for this
wonderful opportunity and to my children
who are up beyond their bed hour please
go to sleep
thank you very much
you